hello
hello
i'm slightly early
can you delay this for an hour i'm going
to the gym
no
i won't
what up smokums
good morning allison
you guys are red today interesting
[Music]
hello
it's going up in the shop sounds good
garrett
thanks for doing that that's really cool
i need a hello emote i always start
every stream by just going hello a bunch
of times
hello samantha
death fiction crimson
yup i had a lot of comments before i
even started the stream everyone was
like yes
this is the best game
do an emote of your face don't already
have that
no i don't think so
[Music]
these are my emotes right here
wait right here those are all our emotes
right now i should get more
i have slots for more
that's okay
[Music]
hello
okay
are you guys ready for this
this
i'm pretty sure this is my favorite game
ever
of any game i've ever played not just
souls games
this is my favorite game
i think
in all of its 30 fps glory
someone earlier said no this is the
worst game ever made
you're
a
troll even if you don't like it you can
say like it's not the worst game ever
[Music]
sekiro is made by from software i would
call it a souls game
i really like that game for what it is
let's just go man
oh yes
i haven't played this game in a long
time and i'm really excited
yanum is the home of blood
administration
you need only unravel its mystery
but where's an outsider like yourself to
begin
easy how is it not a souls game blood of
your own
but first
you'll need a contract
still made by from software still has
the like i don't know
still has all those different mechanics
but it still has the mechanics of
everything i would definitely call it a
souls game
i think you're being a bit
weird about it if that's the case what
is my character's name
[Music]
vaughn
[Music]
winkle
starts
von winkleshart
excellent
i'm old
okay
ordinary happy upbringing
uh high life essence and vigor
highly resilient
rash what's stronger for it
but more strength okay
what are your thoughts on the moog
fought yesterday it's gonna be a youtube
video
it's going out at two o'clock today by
the way
so stick around for that
[Music]
i'm stuck on daughter of cosmos right
now
i'm gonna spend the next few days
farming blood echoes hey there you go
no this is not my first time playing
although i haven't played it in a long
time it's been a few years
i think i always start with military
veteran i think
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
let's just go with what i know
i'm not gonna
you know what i will let's see
big upper body
[Music]
i'm gonna make him a weird ass color
[Music]
i can't even see these colors man
hello
we'll make him pale as hell
perfect
he looks like a von winkle shirt
can you mess with hair
[Music]
should be able to
yup
oh god the
i think the biggest change
for me is gonna be the uh
[Music]
the fps
nice
wait
big pupils
we're tripping out over here dude
red eyes
all right this is fine
winkleshart
is ready
he kind of looks like keanu reeves if he
was pale and had red eyes
[Music]
okay
is he a duke or account i don't know you
decide
von winkleshart is ready to start the
hunt good
all signed and sealed
i've signed my contract let's begin the
transfusion
i don't know what my build's gonna be
we're just gonna play
it's all just a bad dream guys
don't even worry about it
it's all
a dream
it's a crime bloodborne is locked at 30
fps i know
i can't believe they didn't like with
the ps5 release just be like hey let's
release it with 60.
i can't believe they haven't done that
like why not
that is a bad dream right there god damn
oh yeah
oh yeah
i love it
[Music]
and it's amazing those things are turn
out to be so sweet i'm yourself a hunter
you know it
okay
sleep paralysis for the win
excellent
all right how we looking boys
nice and crisp 30 fps
what's this
handwritten scrawl seek pale blood to
transcend the hunt
excellent
i love that
yeah the moog fights going up on youtube
at two o'clock today
i think these are just controls
yep
excellent excellent
who is this guy eating
i just tried to jump attack
you guys see that
i get health back
after
i've if he hurts me
can i parry no i don't have a gun
imagine how scary this would be
i'm basically millennial for the entire
game
there we go
stop trying to okay i'm not even gonna
say that
we don't even need a great rune
to get to get it back this game is
already better than elden ring
why is it an is it
it is every dark souls game or every
souls game
don't you have to die first
let me think
dark souls one i guess you don't
you were just locked away
this one you die elden ring you die
dark souls 2 you die
dark souls 3
you don't
so it's not everyone
the best souls game is lords of the
fallen
okay
okay ludwig
inspect an abandoned doll look guys it's
ronnie
okay so this is how we get to yharnam
this is basically our
teleportation system
[Music]
what do we go with
you don't need to die in this one that's
true i could have just ran by
but to get here
don't you have to die or can you hit the
first lantern and be okay
sakiro you die shadows die twice
i think slaw cleaver is definitely the
way to go i always use saw cleaver
like every time let's just do that and
then a gun
[Music]
hunter i always get this the hunter
pistol
pretty basic i know but we're gonna take
that
then
we got our notebook
closed
dude i miss this so much
this is so good already
okay
so you see that right there boys
you can change your weapon
like it's pretty short right here
now it's long
back to short
[Music]
and what what's the the system rv lb
lb rb lb lb
it does this
like that
rb lb
oh yeah
oh yeah
what does this remind you of
just looking out there
this reminds me of the elden beast fight
where there's all those pillars
or all the trees out there
saw cleaver best weapon funny slapping
pizza cutter agreed
really does look like the elven beast
fight it's kind of weird
man i'm gonna have to get used to this
fps
yeah a little bit like ash leak as well
they have like areas like this in every
one of their games
i think
[Music]
maybe not sakiro
can we buy blood vials
bullets cocktails pebbles here
is lit
jumping's basic
no okay so we have to do it yeah of
course we're gonna do the dlc you
kidding me
of course
awaken at a location
in your selected location
so now we go back to where we were
but we have a weapon to beat up that
wolf
they do love their
pillars i can see why people would be
like oh all the games are connected
because of these things i don't think
that's necessarily the case
i just think they like to use themes
that doesn't necessarily mean they're
all like the same
three blood vials excellent i'm gonna
take him with me
he's my little [ __ ]
okay
where are you more blood vials excellent
restore hp got it i didn't get hurt so i
don't need to yet
i'm here
first time it's my first time in a while
but i have played this before
what am i hearing right now
do i remember how to do everything
absolutely not i'm definitely gonna need
help
from y'all
if you even remember
yeah i fought the orphan before i've
only got one time though
[Applause]
i've only beat him one time
extremely difficult fight but very fun
this way
it's gonna take me a minute to get used
to not pressing y
to pick things up
you're done
you're done
got some bad boys over here
cocktails
hell yeah
where did the are you horny at chat go i
don't know i guess you guys haven't been
horny lately
did that get you horny
excellent
lay up now troy sports you to the
hunter's dream we need to go this way
and unlock that gate
you remember that
game audio is a little bank
i love this world man like th this is
like
this right here i don't know what it is
about it like this victorian gothic
style it is so good
it is so like
immersive
i mean i wish they would remake this
game like remix
it would look so good it still does
obviously but
it's just so nice
please into the eye
i just use the word immersive
what are you doing with that [ __ ] bro
oh i knocked it back
excellent
oh yeah wait
we got all the bad
boys i'm gonna let them pass
can i jump off here
maybe
i need on pc right
i need a remade version on pc
yep just go to england you can
experience bloodborne in in real life
okay we should be able to open this
that is not what i meant to do i press y
uh my bad we can fight this guy we're
definitely dead
if we do just saying this is not gonna
go well
hmm
okay
that kills me
i need to shoot him i need to get good
at parrying again
i think this game has the most
satisfying pairing with the gun
is so nice
yeah visceral whatever okay we can go
this way
i unlocked the door see
we're good
okay let's try that again
oh
[ __ ]
you see his eyes that means he has my
echoes
[ __ ] i don't know the graphs
all right
uh
i think i died in this game the most
of any game
dark souls 3 is the best i really like
dark souls 3 a lot
i'm wasting echoes
not echoes
blood vials
i should talk to gilbert you're right
all right all right all right all right
come on
no i'm doing it for pride
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
[Music]
bruh
come on
come on
i don't know the timing
holy [ __ ]
that scared me
there it is
oh sheesh
look at that
and we got all our blood vials back
let's go talk to gilbert
yeah he literally t post that was weird
god that felt good
what's the hardest souls game
sikiro i think
even though you guys are like it's not a
souls game
yes it is
oh
you must be a hunter
and oh should i move
no i don't care about
a fellow outsider
you must have had a fine time of it
yarnum has a special way of treating
guests
well i don't think i could stand if i
wanted to enemies weak it's just because
i'm this one
if there's anything that can be done
this time this cursed town is cursed
whatever your reasons might be you
should plan a swift exit
whatever can be gained from this place
it will do more harm than good
this man's sick hail blood do you say
hmm
never heard of it
but if it's blood you're interested in
you should try the healing charge
the charge controls all knowledge on
blood administration elden ring is as
hard as you want it to be
elden ring can be the easiest souls game
if you want it to be the healing church
known as the cathedral i think elden
ring might be the easiest souls game
cathedral ward is the old grand
cathedral
the birthplace of the healing church's
special blood
so we need to go to the healing church
that's right
we got to get past uh
don't share much
normally they wouldn't let you near the
place but
the hunt is on tonight
yes it is might be your chance
that pumps me up right there the hunt is
on tonight
oh i like that
i like that
i'm mabel how are you
are you that outsider how do you even
know about sorry but i don't want
anything to do with you
trot along will ya
drop along will ya
anyone here from england is this how
it's like
more blood vials excellent excellent
do i want to fight through this area
probably not but here we are about to do
that
here we are baby
more blood vials
oh god
that was not the timing we want
you're also not worth the bullets
can you kick
is kicking a thing
uk remains largely the same
i've never been outside of the us so i'm
not i don't know what it's like
there's some guy around here that always
scares the [ __ ] out of me
it's not you
like he comes out of nowhere bloodstone
shard that's big
that's our upgrade system there you are
no kick okay thank you
oh look at that
is that not so [ __ ] cool
did they all just hear the
the bell and started moving
i haven't noticed that before
he's coming after me right now
[Music]
it's all my fault
what'd i do man
what did i do
i'm just here
what do you think i did
i didn't give joy enough tummy rubs
this is this is what happens
terrible horrible things
i think jew is the poppables right
that is your dogs because if i did i'm
out i'm leaving
okay
i love the accents man this is so good
so far i love this
average day in eu
the blind is a peak in
peaky blind us
i don't reckon you're from round here
well
stuck outside on a night of the hunt
well
good voice acting
oh man
i love this game
the dlc
is ludwig a part of the dlc chat
[ __ ] dogs in these games man
yes
yeah
have fun with ludwig
that might be the best thing i've ever
seen
is ludwig
sorry i know i'm not running around i'm
just kind of looking around right now
[Music]
yep bloodborne has the best ost in any
of these games
couldn't agree more
you can also beat up people in
wheelchairs
pretty good
time could we listen to the ludwig ost
real quick
he's like if you want to get your blood
pumping
listen to that
yeah the second phase ost
yeah it's 30 fps
save it for when you fight him i don't
just name my youtube account after any
old boss i'm the reason oh that's that's
the reason that's your name that's cool
that's actually cool
wait isn't there another door i have to
open over here
which i think is a shortcut and then i
need to go open the gate
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
bloodstone shard blood vial
right here that's what we want
sister freda is dark souls 3 yes that is
the first dlc ashes of arien dell
i have like
i have just over 2 000 hours in dark
souls 3. you got any questions about
that game
i played the living [ __ ] out of it
i think i have like 500 hours in this
game
but i think it's just like the limiting
factor of the
the playstation a little bit
why i don't play it there
ah doors open
sister frida is extremely difficult but
it's a really fun boss
hello
you must be the new hunter
welcome to the hunters tips we're
starting it after elden ring this will
be your home have fun it's an easier
elven ring well it's not easier
you'll be fine if you beat elden ring
you can beat dark souls 3.
friend to you hunters
you're
don't think too hard about all of this
there's something too hard about it guys
i'll kill a few beasts that's all just
just don't worry about it
everything you're seeing just don't even
you know don't even worry it's just what
hunters do
why we're here baby
dude the lore in this
like i've already i'm already thinking
about the lore in this game and it is so
good it's so incredibly good this was
once a safe haven for hunters i think
this lore is better than eleanor
where hunters used blood to enhance
their weapons
and flesh
uh we'll try and do as much as possible
as we once did but
you're welcome to use whatever you find
even the doll if you wish
should he please you all about your
whispers
okay
okay
god this is gonna be good
fortify weapons with bloodstones
do i need uh
one more bloodstone
to upgrade my cleaver
i have not read the pale blood hunt i've
watched all the videos on it though like
from everyone
it's just so good
okay let's go back
here
elden ring takes
the wild eldress outer god stick from
bloodborne a little bit yeah
how's joy joy's amazing joey's all good
no she's she's probably gonna be joining
us down here today
i wouldn't call any of these games easy
they they can all be hard
for sure
oh no
okay okay come on
look at me go boys
you like that
you like that
i don't like this though
oh i parried the other guy again the
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] bro
i love parrying so much i'm playing a
little scared right now though this game
is
you want to be aggressive in this game
for sure
you know a little passive right now
unfortunately
i really thought he'd turn around
is this the pc mode
if i was playing the pc mode right now i
would have a hundred thousand viewers
so no
that this game is not on pc it's only on
playstation unfortunately
i'd have a hundred thousand people in
chat going how the [ __ ] do you have this
on pc what did you do
how you do this
oh i can't dang it
i gotta go this way
it shut up it has not been released on
pc
the goddamn dogs
these cages open that's why i'm killing
them
there be a few million people watching
there there could be a potential
like no joke
is it l1 r1
r one
l one
oh you're right okay thank you
shutting up indoors isn't always enough
well if you want to get off your asses
you wouldn't be in this mess i always do
r1l1l
are you gonna tell me you're not
[ __ ] the elderly right chat
go on
i do
you suck
no you
[ __ ] you boomer
just a mean boomer
i love that okay
a boomer
must indeed boom
all right let's go see our friend let me
cut this down real quick
excellent
hold
we gotta meet one of the cool characters
i always fall here
as i said
oh i'm dead huh
go go go
move it
oh [ __ ]
nice who am i hearing right now who's
shooting at me
cut it
out
i don't even know how i'm alive right
now
all right well welcome to
the sewers
i swear like the best armor in the game
is right around here am i tripping right
now
i swear it's around this area
which boss did you enjoy the most on
your bloodborne run
i would say ludwig
or um the last one
gearman
spoilers
madman's knowledge
uh you're right but took the wrong route
to get the armor set
how do i get there
i want it now
right now
now what let's go this way
oh you like the pyramid drip [ __ ] yeah
bro
did you just say so
the great bridge
aren't i right next to the great bridge
right there
more blood vials
yo yo
[ __ ] you boomer trying to fool me to
walk on this door
heaven's the depths of depravity trash
ass boomer
i'm gonna be i'm gonna like
vaughn winkleshart
my character
is a zoomer
who hates all boomers
that's my role play
okay what did this open all right all
right
yeah they're literally hiding behind the
screen just like all trolls on the
internet
oh not going up there
y'all can go
in a [ __ ] a ride off if you think i'm
going over there
[Music]
you guys hear that
like a music box
now it's gone
there it is
yeah she right up here
is this her her window
where is her window
guys calm down i will get there jesus
christ
i wanted to kill all the people man
on yourselves
jesus go play your own play through my
god
my parents are getting good again
i'm happy about this okay
i said i walked right past your door huh
there it is
i don't know your voice i am vaughn
winkle charts nice to meet you
daddy never came back from the hunt and
she went to find him but now she's gone
too oh i hate to break it to you honey
i'm scared
sure i'll find your dad uh your mom
oh thank you
my
mom was a red child i am sir
big and
beautiful you won't miss it
oh i mustn't forget
if you find my mum
give her this music box pain
all i know is pain it plays one of
daddy's favorite songs
yeah it does forgets us we play it for
him so he remembers
mom says silly thing enough without it
guys i'm sure her parents are fine don't
you think my mum wears a red jewelled
approach it's so big and beautiful you
won't miss it oh and if you find her
give her this music box please i know
you can do it
you bet
yeah they're fine
they're fine right
they're fine totally fine
um pretty sure i have the elevator
that's cleric beast right
let's go this way so i can activate the
elevator have a bit of a shortcut in
case i die
in case i decide to die
yeah look at those plebeians down there
where does that go i don't want to go
down
guys if you're going to be the type of
people in chat who are like go left go
right go straight no you're going the
wrong way
i want you to right now write down in a
notebook
and then say it out loud to yourself i
am annoying and need to stop talking
okay thank you
okay okay
thank you
i might be a little lost in the sauce
right now
but calm down
on down
it's okay
everything is gonna be fine
hey oh [ __ ] your books
i don't think anything's there
excuse me
all i said was i swear there's an armor
set around here
right you guys go yeah you're pretty
close
i didn't ask for directions
another one
i'm gonna go down here
this seems right
good try bucko
bye-bye
there's a ladder over there
hey ludwig you want to calm down my guy
you're strong
more
oh
that's the army
got it
got it
so
no ways rant [ __ ] you
while you make it seem like you've never
played this i've literally said several
times i've played this game it's just
been a while
why are you making it seem like a little
bit you guys are being annoying bro the
[ __ ] calm down
skill issue at least now i look cool
oh i didn't hit the elevator did i oh
um
fun
why the hell would there be dragons
in a like a renaissance victorian
setting there would be dragons
oh
a hunter ah yeah i don't think there's
dragons an outsider
what a mess you've been caught up in
and tonight of all nights
here
to welcome the new hunter
yay prepare yourself for the worst what
are those do again i don't remember
there are no humans left
they're all
flesh hungry beasts now
damn still lingering about
what's wrong
a hunter unnerved by ludwig is
definitely not a dragon
no matter
without fear in our hearts
a little different from the beasts
themselves
shake off cape
me what are you still doing here i don't
know i like talking trembling in your
boots
a hunter must hunt
oh true
i'll do anything you say mommy
i'll do anything you want mommy
all right guys
where did i die
died somewhere it don't matter
bullets
[Music]
oh this guy
really these guys are so hard
i don't know how that turned into a
paradigm
[Music]
excellent
what's your favorite area
um ask me
when i beat the game again then i'll
know right now i'm not sure
you died near you found the armor well i
know that i just get like turned around
in this area
i really do
let me go down here
okay that's where i fell originally
no
see that's where i think it is and it's
not
i mean at least to me dragons in a
victorian area doesn't make sense
i know there's like monsters and stuff
but it's not really like
like that
it's not like ancient stone dragons
it doesn't give me that vibe
at least to me
okay i went up there just gonna retrace
my steps
can you tell me the generic lore of this
game
there is a hunt everyone's turned into a
beast because of the blood
is it beast blood or pale blood
something like that and then uh
we're a hunter and we hunt
that's all there is to it baby
with a ridiculous amount of extra lore
on top of that
all right tailblood is the hunters
pretty much uh just do it german you
know remember
what he said just don't think about it
we're hunters and we hunt
that's what we do out here baby
whoa
i get a few eyes
joy
this is not not good i'd rather not die
right here
are you okay
ow
well
all right we lost all our echoes
all right
do i have um
well now i don't have echoes
can we beat the cleric beast like this
or should we upgrade our weapon first
i think we potentially
could be hard
no
you're cursed
i'll go this way
they are not runes they are echoes
fist only
i love fisting
i tried to lock on it just wouldn't
excellent
excellent
some more dew actually i have a bunch of
dude that i could pop
just remember that
sorry i'm gonna mimic a lot of the
random noises in the game just because i
find it fun
he shot his boy
you
get out of here crow
i ain't dealing with it
there we go
let's go this way
i think we got a pig under a bridge here
which will be gross
honestly forgot
whoa
all right i'm over we're going this way
you guys like pork
you guys like ham
here you go
god that is terrifying
ooh a saw hunter badge
more but other viles
more dewy boys
oh
right bacon
how could i forget about fakie
okay that could have been death
let's go up here
do you have a moment to talk about our
lord and savior frenzy flame
didn't mean to do that did you bro
you're dead
i think we need to go this way and
unlock the elevator real quick
because we're about to get to the first
boss first main boss
i guess clerk beast is the first boss
and it doesn't matter
here we go
that's all we need to do
this way
let me
put that on
and
that on for no reason at all no reason
guys
don't worry about it
don't worry about the lore
it's really not that deep
what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
damn
what the [ __ ]
those guys go hard
you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna go
upgrade real quick
yes clearly
exactly seal
real i just i i guess that guy saw me as
submissive and breedable
why did i just use that god damn it
okay so
inventory
hold do
use
sticks
i think why do i keep pressing why man
damn it eldon ring okay
bang
okay we need four more so we're not
gonna get that anytime soon
excellent
one upgrade we'll take it
we'll go back
is bloodborne linked to the others
no
they are made by the same company though
i would say no
there are theories out there that they
could all be connected
i personally don't think so
but
again if you want
uh
let's not go get annihilated by these
guys oh wait a minute
oh god
send it
joy die die
away
oh away
bro okay your reach is ridiculous
okay i got my echoes
i got my vials back
we're good we're golden
oh yeah this is just the best
all right you guys ready for this [ __ ]
beast's all over the shop
can you use the box in stage one
be sold over the shop
be sold over the shop you will be one of
them
yeah i figured
he's fine
he's got a cold right
you like that
how often can you use it
uh
oh it seems to me
it's enough to make him out sick
what
[Music]
stop it
i want to use the box
[ __ ]
it's
i can't move
i don't know i'm scared
first try [ __ ]
like that lamp
yeah yeah
yeah i use the box once
uh oh
uh oh you see what i see
oh boy
how do i get up there
oh
boy
oh
no
red jeweled brooch
uh
damn
[Music]
well we go level now
let's get to the church
god damn it
yeah we'll go to the cleric beach we'll
do that
calm down
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm the elden lord
cleric beast
cleric beast please
bobby what the hell is a bussy
workshop tool
take it
god damn it bobby what is a muscle
hey killed bro i love it
[Music]
nice
literally the nicest npc
in all of these games on our right
this one
looks scary as [ __ ] but literally the
nicest pc
oh you must be
a hunter
very sorry 30 frames per second master
master
good
good
i've been waiting for one of your ilk
these hunts have everyone all locked up
inside
waiting for it to end
it always does always as i don't know
about fail blood bobby but
nicely i do know about propane and
propane accessories
the stench of blood
the snarls of beasts none of them's too
uncommon now
yharnam's banned for tell ya
but if you i
they'll be safe here
the incense wards off the beasts
spread the word these nuts tell them to
come on over
if you wouldn't mind
whoa whoa whoa
i'm down my guy
i know i shouldn't be asking you but
if you happen upon someone while hunting
tell them about this here urden chapel
so we can send people here to save them
oh and i'll do sincerely out they are
[Laughter]
okay let's go to the hunter stream
let's level i don't think we can upgrade
anything because we haven't found that
many uh
i forget what they're called already
bloodstone gems our doll it's ronnie
damn she tall as hell hello good hunter
molly calling her ronnie because she's a
doll i'm a doll
as she says in this dream to look after
you yeah
me honorable hunter
pursue the echoes of blood
and i will channel them into your
strength
you will hunt beasts
and i will be here for you
to embolden your sickly spirit
thank you
i do have a sickly spirit farewell good
hunter thanks mommy i love you okay what
is this
consume insight silencing blank in such
forms of vibration
oh okay okay cool that's my uh summoning
bell
let me use
more of these dues
it's our poppy boys
in our music box we have our brooch that
we can give to the girl
cool
8k is not bad welcome home good hunter
what is it youtube
channel my echoes
let me step
what scales with
the cleaver
is it strength
looks like it
skill
no a little bit
i think it's just strength and skill
i feel like our health's a bit low we
have six levels
14
a little bit more strength
let's even that out
like that
that's fine for now
[Music]
excellent
farewell good hunter may you find you
you don't need health if you don't get
hit
true dude okay what's the quickest way
uh i can take the elevator
no
i'm trying to think we got a huge reward
that's what that's called really
i'll just go here
blood tinges for the guns okay
you can use the brooch for your cleaver
instead of a gemstone really is it
is it good
really
really
you guys really want me to fight the
cleric piece so here we go
i think this weapon's my favorite weapon
in bloodborne i haven't experimented
with too many weapons though so i can't
really say
this is my i think this is my favorite
game ever tom
i think it's between this and dark souls
i love the people that come in to chat
and just answer the title
i love it exactly what i wanted
yeah i tried the axe and personally
didn't like it as much as the cleaver
but it was good
you know what i'm saying
yeah i think i needed to go back
i'm just gonna explore anyway
[Music]
i get very lost here
go here and then we can give the broach
to the girl
now i've be i've beaten this game a few
times it's been a few years since i
played it though
i have a platinum on my playstation 4
that broke like two years ago but now i
have a ps5
i've heard the pizza cutters fun
i have tried it it is fun
hey so i found your parents
it went well
hello mr hunter hi
my mom no i found her
yeah
yeah i found her
mr hunter
was it already hot yeah
oh please stop
oh god
oh god
what did we do
oh no
i have not played outer wilds
i've heard it's really good though
maybe we can play it on stream someday
kill the child
don't worry about that
i think i have the rest before doing
this
okay i do i i was about to be like oh no
here
comes oh what the okay who's this
that's some dead guy
that guy did
what are the chances blue point will
remaster this from stop
they sure [ __ ] would get money if they
did
personally
i don't think they need to re
remake it like blue point did demon
souls
why am i going this way where the [ __ ]
am i right now
i did kill gascoigne i already killed
yes coin i'm gonna go here i'm pretty
sure i need to rest i want to get the
ribbon
i'll come back
[Music]
[Music]
okay
now do i just go back
if you played outer wilds on stream chat
would spoil everything in a nano second
oh man
would they really
are you guys gonna be bad
i don't think the smelter demon is in
this game
pretty sure it's not
man bro i i really get lost around here
it's been a while
what
howie
a little early
what the [ __ ] has happened
they're remaking metal gear solid
can we get some new games
like some new ips
i feel like elden ring was the first new
ipod
man i'm really lost in the sauce right
now okay so let's go to the pig which i
think is right here
hello brent
do i have to talk to the girl again
this is usually like a good farm
god damn it i pressed why
i do have to talk to the girl again
yeah i got a wars coming soon that's
true
fog champ
behind me
what about behind me
it's there
i didn't pick it up
oh no
oh there was a second item
red messenger ribbon
what is that
what can i do with that
is it
just look at my inventory
red ribbon that the messengers are oddly
fond of
the thick pungent red was drawn from the
organs of some unfortunate victim
a strange choice indeed but perhaps for
the messengers wearing this accessory
constitutes a form of mourning
uh basically guys the girl left her
house
and the pig ate her and she's dead
so
isn't that nice
you think the state of play is gonna be
mostly hyping up uh
gotta war ragnarok probably
that game is gonna sell so well it's
gonna be ridiculous i think god of war
ragnarok could outsell elden ring
well actually no it won't because it's
only on the playstation so never mind
but it's gonna sell really [ __ ]
good how do i get to the other bridge
like why am i so lost right now
well i have to go over here nevermind i
remember
never mind
bloodborne remaster win
i don't think you guys want my take on
that
i don't think you want my take
it's gonna make you sad
they did add god aboard a pc
eventually
but that's not that's not this game
it's not this game
i've pulled a lot of time sir
i think the next game
in the soul series that we're we're
gonna get
is elden ring dlc and that's gonna be it
for a while
dude this is not where i want to be
either
i'm going up here [ __ ] it
[ __ ] you
oh no
thank god
yeah i did see armored core but i'm not
really excited about that i'm not gonna
lie for you guys
and that'd be like pretty cool i'd play
it
three
screech
here we go
three
three
raining blood i love that
look at my [ __ ] clothes dude
look at my clothes
how does it feel playing bloodborne
after so much elden ring a
it feels amazing
i have played elden ring every day for
seven months
[Music]
and i am
very much burnt out on it
but i love it
however
it's nice to play other games
i think we can all agree on that
welcome what is it
very well let me stan
elden ring overloaded
okay three levels
[Music]
i feel like my endurance could be a bit
better
let's go with this
excellent well good hunter may you fine
bye mommy okay
let's go to the cathedral
i've played elden ring for 11 months
straight
right right right right right right
right
it's very refreshing jared
very very very refreshing
all right
it's time
holy [ __ ] this game is good
oh yeah i forgot about these guys
they're so
creepy oh yeah did you guys see the new
zelda game
that got announced today
what's the name of it again
this is my favorite souls game i
i want to play this in dark souls 3 and
really like again and really make a
definitive answer on that
it's between this game and dark souls 3
for me
then eldon ring is
close behind but behind both of them
who is screeching at me please stop that
it's ears of the kingdom how do you feel
about that
it looks like more breath of the wild
you know
which i don't think anyone would
complain about
more breath of the wild sounds parkers
i only played it uh for a while i didn't
even finish breath of the wild
i played it on a friend's switch and i
don't have one personally so i haven't
played it very much
okay i think there's another path in
here
here we go
yeah i love a shield isn't that the only
shield in the game is that dog [ __ ]
there another shield in the dlc
okay
isn't this another good armor set
yeah should we mix and match here
what the [ __ ]
oh yeah
no spoilers no squares
i don't believe that's the entry to the
dlc
is it
oh god i remember where we're going
though
nice one dog
that dog just ran into the fire and died
excellent
it is the entry after you feed vicar
emilia gotcha
gotcha
okay i don't think we need the tiny box
anymore
considering that entire family is now
dead
gotta kill the hairy priest
is it a priest
priestess
something
about being a mean dog
mean doggy
[Music]
you missing a family member which one
uh we got our boy down here
our sister shows up later you are beast
hunter aren't you that's right i knew it
that's precisely how i started out oh
beg pardon although this guy never turns
around alfred
alfred master lagarius
hunter of vile bloods
so
what say you
i pray i did not know that toad the both
of us
why not cooperate and discuss the things
we've learned
oh
very good
very good indeed
to celebrate our acquaintance
hi booted how are you oh i got a text
i got a text
from
katie
yay
she's very excited
about
the new breath of the wild
yay
we're just talking about that excellent
right stunting is a sacred practice i'm
very good muted
can you guys imagine
if
bloodborne 2
had the same mechanics as bloodborne
but also had the ability to deflect and
parry like you can in securo
and then
in open world
well no i don't want an open world i
want another game like this
mix of sakiro and bloodborne i'm pretty
sure
that would be the best game of all time
i don't need games to be open world for
them to be good
yeah you saw that too booted we were
just talking about that it looks it
looks like more breath of the wild which
is gonna be good
now that sony bought a chunk from
fromsoft
does that mean more like their games are
gonna only be on playstation
wait
i did see that
that's honestly all i want like imagine
like how well do you think this game
would sell if they're like okay so we
made bloodborne remastered
like a total remake even though it
doesn't need that much of a lift up
and they're like it's 20 bucks
everybody would buy that [ __ ]
they would make so much money
and then release it on pc
you can cap it out at like 240 frames if
you want
blood gym contract
contact
they're never going to be exclusive
again
money's money my guy money is money
which is your point but sony could pay
them a lot of money
oh nice i got two
i'd buy it
holy [ __ ] i love this game just walking
around in this game right now holy crap
you want a cowboy western game by from
software
i don't think we're going to get a
better cowboy game than red dead 2. i i
don't think it gets better than that
game when it comes to that aesthetic
that's another game we should play on
stream i i bet you guys would get down
with some red dead i love red dead
okay
that'd be a fun stream game
i'm trying to stream a lot more let's
kind of see how that
goes this is fun what's going on here
this town is long abandoned hunters not
wanted here
so me
here i come
did you guys hear or did you guys see
all the updates to cyberpunk
that's another game we could play
and see if it uh has improved at all
cyberpunk 2077.
which i kind of blanked that game out of
my mind after the release being so bad
i've never played armor core so i don't
really know how to feel about it but
i mean i'll play it i'm not super
excited about it
concert russell's take souls games are
ridiculously
monotonous in between boss fights to the
point of not being fun that's a pretty
hot take
that is a hot as hell take
ceo of jimmy johns
i wouldn't mind trying out cyberpunk
again that would probably be really
interesting
oh god are you weird
i need to check these gemstones because
i think i have a lot of them
hunters torch
yep only 10 more years till gta 6
never played devil may cry
i believe that's called a wrong take
i mean okay so ceo jimmy john's just
like go off what you're saying
do you think what i'm doing like right
here like just walking around and
looking at the aesthetics is monotonous
like this right here
is that what you're saying
oh i have to open it from that side
climbing this ladder
looking for side areas
you say if you gotta take you gotta take
you know
everyone is entitled to their own
opinion
holy
this is such a cool air
contact
yo
i did turn back at once
no
odiana burned and abandoned by men
is now home only to beasts
turn back
that's what i'm here for baby let's go
i'm here for the hunt [ __ ]
why you think i'm here
i don't know what my favorite area is
yet
excellent
i haven't played devil may cry since ps2
but i think you'd like them i've never
played devil may cry ever
what was the other one you guys said
outer wilds
i should write all these down and then
just play them holy [ __ ]
wow
i'd remaster this game it looks pretty
here
just give me 60 frames man i'm already
getting used to the frame rate
though i would say it took me like an
hour to get used to the 30 frames and
now my eyes are like it's fine
you are a skilled hunter
adept oh there he is
i wasn't sure if he'd start shooting at
me there
that's back
dark souls 3 is better we're definitely
going to play that as well
also if you want some of the best gaming
music ever play devil may cry okay
i wouldn't mind trying it out
worse
i'll play whatever you guys want man
i'm here to put out the content for
y'all
i really like dark souls 3 a lot like
that
that could be
we'll see we'll play it
what are some bad areas for you in dark
souls 3 okay there we go
stop it
okay
so
do we want to drop here
i don't remember
it looks like i can go down there
please release it on pc i think that
would be fine
that's all they need to do with this
game is release it on pc
and it'd be good
let me get my bearings
oh [ __ ] hello
nope
not biting you with a gun in the
background
the answer for your title is yes i
figured
we gotta go we gotta get up here
i think
back off [ __ ]
that's right
that's right
that's right
is that how i get to the shooter i don't
think i want to go up there yet actually
that is another thing i have not tried
is neo
i have yet to try neo
whoa
[ __ ]
you guys writing all these games down
because i'm not
poisoning
oh [ __ ]
i didn't like him
one mile back how do i uh
do i have anything that can stop this
yeah the poison is going to go away
you're riding down the bad dark souls 3
areas
oh antidote that's what we need
all right
except it already wore off you dumb [ __ ]
okay
and i already had some
glitch out
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
yo this bad this bad this is bad this
badly bad this is not what we want
okay calm down calm down
holy [ __ ]
ew
relax bro
here's my take on
like
all right here's my take on like why
some people think like some games are
better than others
other souls games
i think whatever game you played first
is gonna be your favorite
and it would take a lot
for another game to be like
yeah it overtakes my first one
in the in this series
is what i mean
unless you play dark souls 2 first then
i'd say about 50 of those people
don't care
they just don't like it
but there is a hardcore dedicated fan
base to dark souls 2.
hardcore dedication
like my first souls game ever was dark
souls 3 in 2016
and then it took
a couple years for me to even get a
playstation for me to play this game to
be like yeah this i like this game more
and i'm still not even sure if i like
this game more than dark souls 3.
i know you're in there you [ __ ] there we
go
there are a lot of cool mods for dark
souls 3 that's true
oh
no this that's our tit shards
dark souls 3 copied so much of dark
souls 1 it
did you hear yourself
never mind
that is such a weird take
it's the same series
oh [ __ ]
oh god
like of course those games are going to
be similar
they literally just made dark souls run
better
in dark souls 3.
i did see the elven ring manga from
zio's video
from yesterday or the day before it
looks pretty cool
more shardy boys
that's from the other boss
thanks joshua i think i'm pretty lured
out when it comes to elden ring but
i i appreciate you watching it thank you
something happens here
right
there it is
these blood pellet those are good
what's in here
this goes to a shortcut i'm pretty sure
i also have a lot of echoes right now
we might want to hit the thingy
we might want to hit a dab
berserker's peak i keep hearing people
don't like berserk but also watch
berserk all the time i don't understand
hello
okay there's our shortcut
excellent
and then go back up here
i rage crate demon souls after an hour
went back to dark souls 1 love both
there you go
sometimes like i've heard so many people
so many people
bro um who hate dark souls or hated dark
souls
then they played bloodborne
absolutely loved it and then went back
and played the souls games and loved
those two
sometimes it just takes one of these
games for you to get into all of them so
you understand
how these games work you know what i'm
saying
[Music]
they copied level design all over the
place we're familiar with dark souls 1
at least dark souls 2 had a new
atmosphere
yeah and then the gameplay was like this
[ __ ] dog [ __ ]
okay so
what you're saying is the thing that
everybody loved in dark souls 1 which
was the level design of dark souls 1
are you saying like in dark souls 3 oh
they just copied the level design of
dark souls 1 man like
no [ __ ] they're going to do that dude
like what's home good hunter what is it
it's what everybody likes very well let
me
one of the biggest strengths
of that game
of dark souls one
[Music]
i'm gonna do level regular
[Music]
no originality besides all of the levels
being different
it never well
why do i do this
we trolling out here welcome home good
what is it
no ignore him he's trolling
he has to be trolling
actually i want more endurance
[Music]
okay four to five
we have 17 of these [ __ ]
god damn
now we need twin bloodstone
got it
[Music]
now we can put gems in these
so this one is
physical attack up
i put that in
oh
i'm confused what
[Music]
that's what i wanted to do okay
a little bit more attack power
[Music]
i'm doing fine uh benetton
we're all good
came to say yes there you go
dark souls 2 is one of the best things i
ever played
that's fine you can have that opinion of
it i played it for six hours and and
couldn't even play it anymore
oh i thought he'd drop down here
he would be nice to get though
uh oh
that was a bit far
damn why i just didn't enjoy it at all i
did not enjoy the gameplay of that game
at all
the bosses were boring
i was dying to like it just seemed like
they were trying to constantly kill me
with mobs instead of like difficulty
of bosses
i just didn't like it
yeah i have channel memberships
of course
this guy makes such a scary noise
but if people really like it then good
for you i'm glad you like dark souls 2.
i'm glad you're having fun
this is our boy right
let's see
these blood pellets good
pungent blood cocktails good
fire paper is good
um awaken a new without losing blood
echoes that's pretty good fathers
blue eyed scotty
thanks for becoming a tarnish man
welcome
see there you go there's a channel
member right there
appreciate it oh i should get antidote
on as well that's true thank you
fair witness
okay
oh yeah i remember this guy
though
let's do this
pop then if i remember right
throw this over here
fire paper
why is that happening i pressed x twice
so
ah
what did i get
[Music]
what the [ __ ] i'm trying to switch
things and it won't switch
i was trying to switch to the antidote
and nothing was happening
hey thank you coach
thanks for becoming a tarnished and
welcome welcome man
i call all channel members a part of the
agency
you used all your stuff
what do you mean
what the [ __ ] is happening
um something really weird was just going
on okay
try that again
link finally worked let's go thank you
coach welcome welcome welcome
yeah i'm pressing the d-pad in like some
weird i don't know
that might have been my fault but we
clearly had him beat we're okay
clearly had him beat
yeah i was using the d-pad and i i swear
i was pressing down on the d-pad and
nothing was happening
i lost my hunter's thing didn't i
all right let's try again
oh now you drop down here huh
three bloodstone shards we need twins
though which i think we have to get to
another area for
unfortunate porch
the game
it just felt weird like i was pressing
down on the d-pad like that and my
character kept reaching
it was weird
is there any lore reason for repeated
bosses no of course not
every repeated boss is a twin
an offshoot
of soldier of god rick
who created all life
there's your lord
that good
do you guys not like the pvp in eldon
ring
i have yet to try it
i haven't even touched it
i don't really like pvp to be honest
okay now we're working
um did that pungent thing just like
completely wear off
okay
let's go over here
keep reaching
whoa
one hit for that huh
let's go back to our corner
[Music]
wait
did i not use the antidote
what is going on right now
[Music]
i don't understand what's happening what
is what is going on
i'm using the antidotes and nothing is
going on
i'm i'm hitting the antidotes and i am
not getting cured
is it a different type of thing
favorite boss in elden ring is radon
i'll parry the poison next time
okay
that's very confusing
i think i'm just
i have no idea that really sucks that we
lost all that stuff
i don't
i think i have to there isn't like a
necessary backstab but i have to like do
a charged attack to his back correct
i think my controller is [ __ ] up
or like
my inputs are weird i have no idea
what's happening
my bad fam
we'll get this dub
your character made blood bullets
that is strange
[Music]
[ __ ]
not the best
not quite on the back
foreign
there we go hello
i was doing the exact same thing as i
was before
that's not what the [ __ ] is happening
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i really don't know what's happening
[Music]
no way
[Music]
one more
my controller is actually
man
[Applause]
i'm scared
[Music]
[Music]
okay
is he doing something
there we go
holy [ __ ] that was annoying
i don't know what's going on with my
controller but it ain't right
oh i need to get the hell out of here
okay there we go
i think the combat in sequiero is just
like indigenous ingenious idea once you
get it's like oh
it's like a um
i would call shakiro like a
rhythm game
don't you
you think have any poppy boys no poppy
boys
welcome
what do you desire
two
excellent
more antidotes behind the altar of that
boss hopefully we don't have to go back
there for now
um we need to go back
here
i love skiro but i don't think it's a
part of soulsborne i do 100
it absolutely is it is
different mechanically like
gameplay-wise but it has all of the same
what would you call it all of the same
all the same blood
you know
well ah the hunter
alive and well are ya
this is a safe place stay as long as you
like
but
next time you're out on a hunt remember
what i asked
if you find any squishies nothing right
okay
this wasn't open before
dude i was looking at my weapon too and
i'm like where is my where's my
my my cleaver literally disappeared for
a second and i was like what is going on
[Music]
communion what is that
roon
oh this is not my first impression
played this game
a lot a long time ago
okay
yep
yep
it's very good
oh my god
don't remember all this
i sure don't
ruin helps you hold more vials really
why'd i do that
don't ask
miyazaki
has said in multiple interviews that he
doesn't like making sequels and the only
reason he made dark souls 3 is because
of dark souls 2
which he didn't have a ton to do with
no he had trusted it to somebody
and it did not go well
so
he might not make sequels voice
we don't know
we'll see
he likes making new stuff
how do i open that
remember
wait is there a lever right next to it
i've been through that door before
sometimes you gotta stop and stare
pretty
you're finding some cold blood i like
that
oh yeah we're playing everything
of course of course
kidding me this game's too good not to
play all the way through is there
somewhere else
i don't think so okay
couldn't figure out how to unlock it
you just uh got to get grabbed
don't you guys love how like from
software always has a really unique way
of getting you into the dlc
like it's its own discovery
i think that's awesome
there's a key in
yargold
i have to defeat rom to go through there
so i'm too far ahead got it okay
we need to go back
i think um i got the chalice to go to
vicar right
yeah it takes you down to the old
workshop
or the area that the old workshop is in
right
i believe so
that was
me put it out
[Music]
okay
[Music]
man went off
oh
definitely uh don't need to lock on
there
did not help
only a special emblem opens the main
gate got it
and what did i forget
you guys talking about
i love the limb brake system me too it's
really cool
it's not like
god damn this place is pretty it's not
uh super obvious but once you figure it
out it's really cool
i don't like this situation
i don't like it
okay that guy is baller
isn't there a door over here that nobody
has opened ever
got a chest
[Music]
nice
this door right
it does not open nobody has ever opened
it
i wonder if it's a thing like you can
but no one's figured it out
balling
i'm having a good time for lauren
um dungeon
is there somewhere to go over here
hell no just another broken bridge
that's a door
where am i going boys
hello hi trey
thank you for the five dollar super chat
that is very kind of you thank you
i already went this way
how do we get to vikkar amelia
vikkar amelia
thank you trey how are you
now
vic karen amella
you don't what
i thought she was like second boss
i'm forgetting
i thought there was a way to go around
right
am i tripping
am i tripping on these nuts right now
yeah the frame rate i had to it took me
like an hour to get used to the frame
rate
you can either go through the old
hunters workshop or use the emblem
i thought that was down like some hole
you go back to the tower second floor go
outside drop off the edge
oh
so i i missed it okay thank you
i don't want to use i don't want to
spend 10k
hell no bro
i'm broke is a joke
kidding me
are you kidding me bro
yeah i'm not broke anymore with trey's
five dollar super chat [ __ ] yet my dogs
are hanging out in the office with me
and farting a lot i am unwell
what do you mean dude that sounds
amazing
just kidding
hello
fall
die oh i need to go down here huh
yo twin blood let's go
yep i found it i remember dying here a
lot
a lot of a lot
okay
another [ __ ] platforming thing
that i remember that isn't so bad
i'm just dumb
messenger top hat adorable
did we wear the top hat
it's not as good
but we do look fly as [ __ ]
and this hunter is really good
i mean we look good as [ __ ]
god damn it bobby
gearman i think is the best boss that or
ludwig
that or ludwig
do i have to drop right there
how do i get there that's where the old
shop is right
bastion is more important than stats i
agree
top hat
this is like exactly the same
now i think i like the other one more
oh they're both hunter guards they're
just a little different
i like this this looks nice
emilia you go all the way down right i'm
just scared of death you know
like that was very close to death
okay
okay
oh we got a bad boy
what
[ __ ] this i don't know why he scares me
but he does
that guy scares the [ __ ] out of me
stay
use the torch too dark
too late
too late
stop
where does this go
damn i look sick as hell
the ward
do i want to jump here is this the is
this the workaround
you're
and then it'll be these two bad boys
let's go
let's go
progression
[Music]
oh [ __ ] my ass
please
what is this guy doing
let me [ __ ]
give me that health back
i can't see anything
oh you're not dead
no item
it's just a good time from now on people
i want to open that don't i
probably
go go go go go go go go
excellent
did you find one of those bag men
uh the one i just spot yeah
yeah yeah
that's something
actually i should probably go level
and upgrade
now that we have uh
yeah i don't need these right now okay
which we imagine
excuse me
are you kidding
since i've never seen one of those guys
have a gun
and he just spammed me it's like call of
duty out here
okay i can go grab him and then come
back
run
go go go
i have 11 inside
oh
now
oh boy
all right who took him
who's got him
it's you
wait do i have to grab them
i know i had more than this
what happened to all my echoes man
did i not have that much
i thought i had like
8k i might have been tripping
go go go
i killed the guy with the glowy eyes
i did
what i do wrong
i'm son of a [ __ ]
one of the enemies you killed might have
picked them up
oh suck my ass please
please
oh i need one more
[Music]
is it worth upgrading your pistol
yeah that's true i didn't see the big
message
is it worth upgrading a pistol
i don't think so
a gem
so we got
physical attack
up 1.1
i mean that's literally just better so i
don't know why i wouldn't use that
wait
right okay cool
if you're going for a blood tinge build
right okay
ophelia
welcome what is it
what is it you desire chat
what would you like
what do you need chet
what is your heart's desire
i'm going to go get my echoes
and then we're going to fight
amelia
which is a very cool fight
very cool
i swear i killed the guy with the purple
eyes but i think i got confused with
this purple light
yep no purple eyes there
dog doesn't have it
oh
why are they right here
what
i died way over there
interesting
i died like right there
should i go spend them should i go spend
them should i go spend them
yes
don't be dumb
be smart
because we're smart
that alden ring mains would be like i
imagine if you could just pick out your
map and go back to the round table right
now instead of having to run all the way
back to a lantern
kind of weird bro
kind of uh
kinda bad bro
the mom called me
oh trey you still in chat i can answer
your text actually hold on
you're my mom called me uh-oh
hold on i gotta meet you guys
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
i'm back
hi
mom is good you just had a question
very well
very well
[Music]
i want a game in the same level of elden
ring i hate all games after elden ring
so you're saying eldoning elden ring
ruined all of their games for you
hi
get andy get the [ __ ] let's get the [ __ ]
let's get this [ __ ]
that was a weird non sound there
elton are gonna make me dislike most
other open bolts
elden ring revitalize my love for gaming
i played four souls games bloodborne
twice and platinum skiro after elven
ring there you go man that's what it did
for me
it made me want to play these games
again
um
honestly i thought
i thought open world games were bad like
i didn't even enjoy them that much
um i liked skyrim a lot when it came out
but it kind of came out a long time ago
um
open world games to me throughout time
were like
just these giant barren wastelands of
like nothing and then eleanor came out
i'm like holy [ __ ] this is awesome so
i think it i think it's the best open
world game and then it made me
appreciate these games too
and for like people like uh
keanu
it it made them go and play the other
ones too
which is it's great
because these games are incredible
that we're very niche for a long time
yep i think a lot of people appreciated
how it didn't hold your hand
um a lot of people hated that because
they're so used to like open world games
telling you what to do all the time
which i absolutely hate
is ready for some screeching
exactly blue
eyed exactly
and that's so good
it's amazing
i streamed on twitch for four years
[ __ ] up
[Music]
oh i could have this rolled her face
wait i still can't
i do not like where we are
[Applause]
i'm beating up that limb
a little bit too much
yes
me that face
it's like i'm good at these games boys
it's like i'm good at these games
god damn
god damn little rp walk away
i mean sheesh
it's like i have a thousand hours in
this game or like 500. it's like 500 to
1000. it's not even that
much thank you elden ring
hello juliet how are you mr william
i've come to bid you farewell
uh-oh oh i know i know
you think now to betray me
no
but you will never listen
i tell you i will not forget our adage
our adage
we are born of the blood
made men by the blood
undone by the blood
our eyes are yet to open our eyes the
old blood
i must take my leave
i'm doing great thank you for asking
yeah the old blob
so his pupil pieced on him
lawrence did
oh my god his skull
lawrence left
god damn this game is good
this game hits all the right
all the right notes
fear the old blood
got a lot of echoes
very well let
let's do
that and then
spring
[Music]
you don't like lawrence yeah i can see
why
i see what you're saying
let's see where else can we go
i might have to call the stream here
i think
because i got about 20 minutes until
uh
the video from yesterday comes out
and i don't want to be live while that
video goes up
because i have it scheduled for 20
minutes from now
get kidnapped
we could
both
i suppose
hello
first souls game is bloodborne after
that i have played dark souls 3 elena
now i'm playing dark souls demon souls
remastered
or dark souls remastered
how to pick up fair maidens does it
actually
should i get captured
yeah [ __ ] it
let's get captured
when i stand like right here
yep
it didn't work
huh
do i not have enough
insight
not that one oh where do i get captured
then i thought it was that one
oh that's the dlc huh
[Music]
oh i know what you're talking about now
i didn't mean to go all the way in [ __ ]
go back go back
i don't even think that was the right
one was it god dang it
yeah i have to let a lot of those things
catch me
okay sorry i'm [ __ ] up here
our eyes are yet to open
[Music]
cathedral award
[Music]
man did the ps5 even like increase load
times
or like decrease load times
it doesn't feel like it it still feels
pretty long
all right i get captured by this thing
right yeah
yeah yep
throw me in your bag
oh you just killed me
i'm gonna have to get off in a little
bit in your vintage
we got the video from yesterday's moog
thing going out at two o'clock enjoys
barking
joey
joy's barking
all i have to do is die to him
yep
i was supposed to die
[Music]
well not really
we'll be back tomorrow though
joy is very upset right now
there must be
a dog outside or a deer or a squirrel
something she don't like
all right boys
i gotta get out of here
i gotta get out of here
we have a new video coming out on the
channel in about 10 minutes 15 minutes
so stick around for that if you want to
comes out at 2 o'clock
gotta go take care of the doggy we are
going to continue this tomorrow around
the exact same time
appreciate y'all being here this is like
actually really fun to play again it's
been a long time since i played it so
hope you're enjoying it
um but we'll be back tomorrow
so have a great rest of your day
have a great night have a good evening
sleep well
hello
and i appreciate you guys so we'll be
back tomorrow
have a good one
and take care
bye guys bye bye